this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands 500 weapons from
throughout history and this week he's
taking a look at Dead Island 2's Zombie
Survival Arsenal we've got a nail gun
here now I'm not keeper of nail guns I
don't know if any real ones work this
way but they um insert the magazine nail
carrier and then slapping down the
handle on the top if anyone Works in
construction let us know because I'm
sure you're all slapping them like like
you are let me fights make sure to
subscribe and let us know what other
games or guns you'd like to see Jonathan
breakdown in the comments section down
below right let's take a look at the
guns of Dead Island 2.
pretty conventional looking polymer
framed apparently Striker Fired pistol
here looks quite a bit like the Taurus
24 7. it's its own design pretty much
but it's also quite close to the Taurus
I think because it's quite believable in
the way it's depicted and handled what's
really weird though of course being
being a Dead Island game is that we've
we now have some bizarre attachments so
it's like an electrifying muzzle device
thing to to deliver this is this is a
role-playing game isn't it basically so
we have electrified bullets because of
course bullets and electricity is worse
than just bullets isn't it so kind of
like Taser Taser rounds that are somehow
delivering electrical energy wirelessly
let's not overthink that aspect too much
the aspect I am going to overthink
though is the complete lack of any hole
in the muzzle device so if you were to
attach this to your whatever pistol and
pull the trigger it it would go boom
because there is nowhere for the
pressure to go that's a bit of an
oversight one that I would imagine is
fairly easy to fix and they might please
don't bombard them with comments and
complaints but when you have the ability
to when you have something rendered in a
decent amount of detail and it's it you
know you can rotate it and look down the
barrel we're used to seeing rifling down
the barrel the projectile itself all
that lovely detail so when all you see
is a flat bit of texture you think um
[Music]
this rifle although it looks quite
Accuracy International is fairly closely
based on the Russian sv98 fault action
rifle which is quite reminiscent of the
AI actually but with more of a sort of
sculpted organic look to the chassis to
the stock these these sort of Divergent
slope of the bottom of the receiver stop
um using three words for the same thing
now and the magazine is kind of a
giveaway and it's very oval shaped
trigger guard curved pistol grip it's
it's an sv98 or or close to it clearly a
type of precision rifle that should have
a scope on it I don't know if you can
get one in the game or something but I'm
not seeing one here
oh
I see the green muzzle device which has
some sort of little tank thing under it
as well on the muzzle of the gun uh the
rifle is acid should have realized video
games and and green equals acid usually
and there's a flame version as well that
we also saw there different ways of
causing aggravated damage I suppose the
the role players would call it fine I
guess but um it's not my style of zombie
gaming gameplay I'd rather have the
traditional remove the head or destroy
the brain thing than just doing more
damage to their bodies if they're
supposed to be dead anyway doesn't sort
of intuitively make much sense that you
would be looking to do more types of
damage to them but I'll that's just old
man shouts at Sky so I'll leave it there
foreign
to anyone that we have an AR and
harmonic rifle in this game possibly
more than one this is clearly in sort of
DMR configuration and I recognize that
upper receiver very reminiscent of one
that appeared in Modern Warfare Modern
Warfare 2 2 that we covered previously
and that is a slightly obscure upper and
lower receiver set from a couple of
forgive me for calling you obscure Mega
Arms but um I wasn't aware of you before
I am now a company called Mega Arms who
um Activision clearly based their design
on now the lower in this case is not
that in fact it's it's possibly
something else with that recessed Square
above the magazine well on the magazine
housing that's sort of ringing a bell as
well but I can't think what that would
be but the upper is a take on that that
design albeit the angled cuts on the
sort of tubular section of the or what's
normally a tubular section of the AR
upper they're vertical on the on the
real one I think uh yeah a few other
details that don't quite line up with
that but it it's eerily similar yeah
let's see this thing in action
foreign
slightly I just want to briefly comment
on the damage modeling as it were so we
have a riot gear zombies and we're not
using the Zed word in this game it seems
I thought we did first time around but I
could be wrong the rightful caliber
bullets are striking this Riot helmet
and not going through right away which
they absolutely would even a true
ballistic helmet does not typically
resist I mean even if if this is even if
this is only five five six only five
five six
um it should be going straight through
both sides and the head and out the
other side certainly for a uh a riot
helmet which is just to protect your
head from Impact damage it's not not
ballistic certainly not normally anyway
foreign
okay it doesn't look like we have a
suite of ARS in this in terms of the DMR
and the assault rifle they are different
they've got different receiver
architecture as it were and the
handguard arrangements are different it
does have the US military M4 as opposed
to M4A1 burst function rather than
automatic in fact the receiver has got
the word burst written on it that
appeared we seem to be having some
mirroring here some graphical mirroring
to some extent because the fire selector
text is backwards on the right hand side
of the lower not too much to say about
this thing other than it's a civilian
build they are in sort of in context and
in detail but with a burst trigger
mechanism in it which is a little bit of
a contradiction I guess it's it's a
gameplay thing so you're not able to
just hose this thing but the burst rate
is a bit low for M4
m16a2 this thing does suffer from
extraneous wraps and strips there's like
black tape wrapped around part of the
butt stock that would do nothing as far
as I can tell except that I can't see
how you would extend it so maybe that
catch broke and that's holding something
in place it doesn't really make sense
there that's a minor thing and then
there are what look like elastic bands I
don't know about bungee cord I think in
several places on the hand guard that in
theory might be holding down a pressure
switch for a light or something but they
don't know what they're doing anything
here
all right
all right a somewhat disguised Ingram
model 10 AKA Mac 10 we have one here
this one always amuses me I don't know
if you can see on camera but this one
was made in Tunbridge Wells in blighty
Jolly Old England that's just probably
only of amusement to me and maybe a
couple other Brits in the audience but
this is this was made by a company
called SF Firearms it has a an unusual
shaped grip the Ingram is normally
tubular or like box suction steel with
then a back strap in in polymer on the
rear of it this is more uzi-like in that
it has what you still have the box
action underneath but there's a wrap
around polymer grip with ribs on it and
it gives it a bit more of a Dead Island
2 look but it's not not the same the the
game and the gun in the game is
substantially more different notably in
having an angled grip more like a
traditional pistol grip and magazine
respects that angle so the magazine is
sitting at a rate angle that's quite
rare in machine pistols and small uh
some Shin guns because
90 degrees is the best angle for
Reliable uh presentation of the round to
feed reliably however modern pistol
caliber Firearms often do because
they're usually designed around
something like a Glock magazine which is
designed for an angled pistol grip and
therefore comes in at an angle a very
round about way of saying that it
doesn't match the traditional style of
Ingram or Uzi or whatever but it
wouldn't be by any means impossible in
fact I think I've seen custom lowers for
m10s and m11s that do have an angled
magazine so something like this could
exist it's just that it doesn't not
looking exactly like this but the upper
Parts this distinctive the two two ribs
on this side the ejection port on this
side and the angle of the lower receiver
the very boxy design of the Ingram is
all there even the I removed the stock
on this one makes it look more like the
one in the game which has a swivel on
the back of it you can see that the rear
side light even has the these two
perforations as well as the side
aperture giving you the three holes in
the Triangular bit of metal just like
the gun in the game so there's no doubt
that that gun is based on the Ingram M10
foreign
Smith and Wesson performance center
something or other not a model we have
in the collection we have we have many
Smith and Western revolver designs uh
variants in the collection but um as in
many cases we are lacking some of the
more modern material so not this one but
I do recognize the the form of the
barrel and some fairly Telltale Smith
and Wesson queues in the design as well
quirky feature of this thing is the
metallic sound I'm hearing and I'm only
really hearing it when we're aiming with
the sights here there's a sound almost
like a bullet hitting a steel plate and
I think it's meant to be the the gun
operating somehow and we're for some
reason the difference between holding it
at arm's length and holding it I guess
closer to your face is that loud
clanging sound which is really odd the
acid tank on the front still makes no
sense makes my brain hurt the actual
behavior of the gun is pretty good I
think that I like the The Recoil
depiction you get a sense of how
unsteady your bones and tissue is
when you fire a magnum fast revolver it
will tend to not only pull up and left
but also kind of wobble as well so it's
quite naturalistic in that in that
depiction the reload's okay
um if anyone has a revolver please don't
flick the cylinder shut on it I have it
on good authority from gunsmith that
that does in fact damage your gun
perhaps worth doing in a in a zombie
apocalypse but otherwise don't
all right
[Applause]
so I've just been presented with a range
of different shotguns that are all the
same shotgun and I believe well to be
fair it's a mashup receiver shape is
probably Remington 870 which is what
this Riot gun I guess you'd call it or
entry entry gun but the distinctive
shape of the 870 trigger guard is not
there the bolt is flat face more like a
Mossberg so I think it's a sort of
fantasy shotgun in any case in terms of
Short Pump actions this is probably the
coolest that we have
um and it's more if anything Duke Nukem
3D so that's the that's our little short
870. the game kind of goes a bit nuts so
we end up with more of a proper tactical
shotgun configuration long barrel fixed
stock there was
um the M4 stock adapter which is the
plague of the Firearms world as far as
I'm concerned and then on that variant
there was a really curious uh Spas 12
front end it looked like uh I think what
they call in the car world of cuts and
cut and shut where the front half was
fast 12 still pump mode not the semi
mode and then the back half was still
870 Mossberg 500 which made it look
quite weird and I'll say video gaming
but um video games are normally more
spot on for realism than that but this
is not by no means a realistic game so
I'm not I'm not holding it to those
standards but if you show me this stuff
I'll tell you about it
foreign
now I'm not keeper of nail guns and I
know very little about them we do stray
into a non-strictly firearm areas in
some areas like Humane killers that kind
of thing signal pistols but we don't
deal with powered tools which uh
cartridge nail guns are now this is some
sort of Electric System that I believe
exists but I know nothing about so I
can't really comment on the realism of
that except that much like the uh Denzel
Washington equalizer movie which is
fantastic but nail guns don't aren't
that powerful at that distance this one
has also had some weird pistol sights no
more nails done to the top for some
reason I don't know why they bothered
with that and the Damage dealt by these
nails is basically identical to at least
some of the bullets in the game so the
the sort of balance of this being an
expedient weapon is it seems a bit off
to me but then I don't really know how
it fits within the the ecology ecosystem
of the game but it seems a bit too
powerful that I like the I don't know if
any real ones work this way but the um
insert the magazine nail carrier and
then slapping down the handle on the top
uh does make it feel quite like a gun I
imagine if that is something on nail
guns if anyone Works in construction let
us know because I'm sure you're all
slapping them like like you are mp5s
those were the guns of Dead Island 2. as
always check out our if you can our
three museums here in the UK and if you
can't we've got various things online
here at the Royal armories Facebook
Instagram Twitter and head over to our
own YouTube channel if you'd like for a
bit more of a deeper dive on historic
firearms